it's been two years since some of
india's most
recognizable rights activists were
rounded up and taken away by police
they're accused of instigating violence
during a march by disadvantaged hindus
in maharashtra state where one person
was killed
eighty-year-old poet vadavadarao and
prominent human rights lawyer sudha
bharadwaj
are among the detained their arrests led
to nationwide protests by their
supporters
most of the 11 accused are yet to be
formally charged
in delhi sudha bharadwaja's daughter
maisha reads a letter from her mother
sent from jail in mumbai what is this
this is not fair and it's not a joke
right
this is her life this is my life and
they're ruined
they are ruining our life
human rights lawyer shalom has worked
with sudha bharadwaj for 10 years
she says only one of the 11 accused was
at the march
we feel right from the beginning it was
a very politically motivated case
as far as a criminal case goes there is
no evidence it is really that
politically it was thought that these
people need to be punished for the work
they're doing
all of them are very well known very
well reputed human rights activists
no stranger to prisons having previously
spent 10 years in jail for inciting
communist revolutionaries
but he has never been found guilty his
family are calling for his immediate
release
after he contracted coronavirus in
prison
we are very much worried about his
health and his
life this is a question of life and
death
because he is 18.
critics say the government is using
anti-terrorism legislation which allows
detention without charge
or trial human rights watch is among
many groups
asking the government why it hasn't
investigated the alleged role
of hindu nationalists in the violence
that rao and baradwaj are in jail for
even though a fact-finding mission found
hindu nationalist leaders
were responsible no justice the bjp
government insists there's no political
interference in the case
because the accusation is that the bjp
government protects
it it doesn't matter the government
doesn't come into the picture
it'd be 100 people yeah in a democracy
because 100 people are saying something
that doesn't become the truth
because there are a thousand people who
say no they were not involved
myself advantage is waiting for her
mother's next bail hearing
she's been joined by the united nations
and european parliament
who are calling for the release of human
rights defenders
elizabeth piranham al jazeera new delhi